but you're looking for the exception and
not the rule contraceptions per is works
99.99
of the time yeah so so that's that's
like it kind of takes away from the real
argument because you're looking for the
one-off cases and same with grape that's
that's the exception it's not the rule
but why do we why do we go okay so you
made a mistake or you were naive or you
didn't take this contraception now we're
gonna punish you forever because that's
basically what you're doing when you
withhold the right to an abortion no i
think i think you weren't naive i think
you were irresponsible and i think you
could have you could have made you could
have made better choices and not been in
that situation i was going to and and my
mom was in that situation what about
kawasaki
and my mom was in that situation she was
17 she had no money she was broke and
she she did the right thing she gave my
brother greg up for adoption i see him
today he's like 30 he's got he's married
he's a software engineer it's like how
are you going to say that's not a life
but how do you think that's the right
thing
yeah why because because i think life is
intrinsically valuable right but then
that means if that's so you believe in
obviously pro-life yeah right
what was the reason for that it's
interesting
no no because i i think conception
begins at like i think life begins at
conception right but there's also
scientific
evidence that actually shows that
actually a bunch of collective cells
don't represent the human life well why
you know when you conceive a child like
it has a unique genetic coat so you can
see what eye color it has you can see
the personality that it's going to have
you can see like all these different
genetic features that that kid's going
to have at the moment of conception and
like the brain starts to develop develop
immediately she's having those brain
activities
right
but human a human being isn't actually
human being until the brain is actually
developed
and
actually have cognitive behavior do you
know i mean such as crying such as um
pain okay so what about someone that's a
vegetable like like that they don't know
i'm serious so if if they need to have
cognitive behavior what about something
definitely
again you're looking at the exception
and not the rule no but i'm talking
about the the academic argument so i'm
talking about like if if your argument
is that it has they have to be like full
of life they have to be able what was
the word you used
um cognitive behavior yeah cognitive
behavior if that's if that if that
determines life then what about this
being the vegetable yeah so like like is
there life not does that not count as
life of course it counts as life but
some people do say
that what is the value of a person who
is a vegetable of their life what is the
actual quality of life if that person is
a vegetable like there have been
scientific studies where people actually
do look into a
person who actually doesn't have that
activity yeah and then what does that
equal to because there's obviously a
definition for human beings and if that
doesn't match up to being human being
then what more can we say not trying to
be insensitive but i'm literally just
looking at it from the factual but i
don't think that's insensitive because a
lot of people that come out of
vegetative states um
and are not able to come back to their
their function as they were before
um they say that they would rather their
family had
because yeah they they cannot live like
how am i living if i can't do anything
for myself because obviously like as a
baby or as a as a child you have to
learn along the way but if for the rest
of my life if i have to depend on you if
i know that i have the ability and it's
taken away from me and i can never gain
it back
then i think it goes to your point of
saying like what is the proof but my
question for you pearl is if you're
valuing life at conception what are you
doing
uh postpartum to value the life or like
show that as valued because if if all of
these lives are valued uh and they
should be valued and i don't i don't
think that any human is less um
significant than the next one i believe
that we are all equally important but my
question is if
we are so valuable as
a columbus cells of as you are saying
and after the baby comes out what are we
doing
or what are you doing as a not you
specifically and not your parents
because i know you're going to say that
like you know
yeah your adoption but and i'm not like
taking away from that but my point of
thing is
there are so many pro-life people that
are not adopting and saying i value life
but then when the life is here oh do you
see them oh oh they're asking for a
handout they're asking for a handout so
if if i already know and not me
specifically like just in general if i
know beforehand i'm not able to sustain
this life if i'm not able to cater to it
like nurture the nurture of the baby you
know instill these values that that
you need to be able to live a life
if i cannot do any of these things then
how's the life really being valued and
did you get what i'm saying you're
saying
what i'm saying like like it's just what
if you ask me that question i'm gonna
say my family took in three kids that
that aren't there but what about the
rest of the pro-life people because
obviously there are a lot more like you
know so
no but i'm saying if you look online or
even like say say the videos of people
outside of planned parenthood and it's
like you know adopt a dog and there's
nothing wrong with adoption yes of
course adoption because we need these
people to be integrated into society and
to be loved and you know like we as
people we need the connection and we
need to be loved but the thing is if
you're like shouting oh like
this is this
the bible literally says like god is
saying like if you have colon uh your
eye why are you pointing at your brother
so if you're saying you know like oh
adoption adoption but then i'm not
adopting how the hell am i telling you
what to do and i'm not instilling that
well but i'm saying that's that's not
true i'm no i'm telling you i've been in
multiple different communities like like
i'm from illinois i lived in london i
lived in wisconsin i've been in multiple
different churches there's a lot of
people that adopt in churches that tend
to be pro-life
there's a lot of people doing really
like really great things
and and so so that's like it just seems
like you're like you're kind of
prejudiced against people that are
pro-life because that's your
interpretation but i know so many
that have adopted themselves i think
part of the problem is that
i
as someone who's pro-choice
it's exactly that i believe in a choice
if you want to be pro-life if you want
to not have an abortion you don't
believe in that whether it's for
religious or moral or just you know you
don't think you could deal with that
emotionally or the physical toll of that
that's completely fine with me like
again that's your personal choice but i
do not think that anybody has the right
to sit there and dictate
what i can and cannot do with my body
especially not on the foundation of
religion like i know within texas
obviously very very religious in the
bible very christian and a lot of the
guiding principles for laws there are
based around christianity
well now you're completely infringing on
my religious rights
because you're imposing on your your
it's not religion though if you're if
you had a a month old baby and you
killed it in your house
like they're not the same thing this is
to me to me to me it's life to you it is
yeah other people it's not on that right
right we can't we cannot we cannot sit
here and physically prove this is the
thing we cannot sit here we cannot
but you cannot conflate the two things
they are not the same thing they are so
not the same thing so
that for me is is another is another
issue of it it's not viable outside of
the womb up until a certain point i
can't remember exactly how well neither
20 is 20 years old
most babies aren't viable on their own
outside of the like even when they come
out they're still dependent on their
mother
to yeah but i'm saying even with the
best healthcare in the world even with
you raising it i'm saying that that
fetus is not viable in any sense of the
word it would die
um
like it's because to me it's just it's
not your body it's the baby's body no
it's not but it's not what because you
made that body at the end of the day you
made that body from your own single cell
organism right even if you do if you if
you do believe in not killing life right
that means i would assume
that you wouldn't believe in
contraception right because you are
killing single cell organisms through
their conception right like condoms yeah
yeah yeah you are because you're not
allowing the sperm to actually you're
killing off this right so you prevent
conception no but the thing is right so
then you end up killing that's not this
then every time someone jacks off it
would be an abortion
but you're actually in the
um action of conceiving right you're
meant to be technically we're not even
meant to have contraception biologically
no no i'm saying that then every time a
guy masturbates it would be an abortion
so that's what i'm saying you can't just
say this
remember what i'm saying is we don't
actually have a comprehensive
cell that's how you think it's a living
cell and it moves and you're saying but
it doesn't have a unique dna code okay
called embryotic cells then
and when they did stem cells stem cell
um therapy or whatever it is like ivf
they put they put two cells together and
sometimes they just throw them out
yeah it's it's yeah there's so many
ethical reasons that come down to even
embryonic cells in general when it comes
down to stem cell therapy and i don't
even know if it's
illegal
it might be illegal in the states i'm
not 100 sure i don't know if they're
doing it or not but like it might be i
think it is a legal um thing but it's
just i don't think it's always been
illegal i feel like they have been
testing out otherwise it wouldn't be
illegal as to this date so if that's the
case people wouldn't be out here using
um anti-wrinkle injections and
steroid creams that actually have
embryotic cells in them
i don't i'm going to be i don't know
anything about ivf like i'm not a
satellite oh no this is just stem cells
i don't know it's heavy
when you get like a man's sperm salad
yeah and then grow it in grow it like
outside of the body yeah
yeah
so like
concepted right
a fetus a potential fetus would die
because you put two together that's
technically conception are you talking
about like in a petri dish
technically you've got like let's say
you've got like 20 000 conceptions
but you only take like 10.
are we gonna like fight scientists and
people doing that as well because like
life starts at conception are we going
to target those people as well that are
doing ivf they're bringing life into
this world
because like i feel like
that kind of alternate views like with
what i love conservatives believe they
want to bring more life well i i can't
really speak on that because i don't
understand like ivf yeah it's really
simple it's like male cell female cell
together outside the body absolutely
yeah and they put it basically
and so so let me just understand so
you're saying it would be an abortion
like in the in the petri dish well
technically if you throw that out you
say well this is the best one and they
have a unique dna code yeah both of them
do all of them because it's not um
when you go for example like that's what
the sperm banks are for because for
example as a man right you go and let's
say for example you donate right yeah
and like turn backs are then as doctors
or whatever the scientists work on it
like some some sperm is used and some
sperm is
you know is like not used because it
dies
they do kind of like separate it to wear
it and then from then on
whether a woman wants to use that or
they can do like like you said like the
petri dish thing yeah obviously but in
some no it's not abortion because
sometimes the cell itself can't survive
or so
you know i mean but like like all the
eggs will be fertilized for example and
not all of them will survive
into the woman
but technically that's conception
because both the male cells and the
female cells have joined they're just
going to put the stronger
stronger embryonic cell into the body
the rest will be thrown away
isn't that is that
in the woman's in the sense of
perception yeah in the sexes in the
sense of conception because she chose to
go down the road of ivf so do people
that do ivf are they bad people because
they are aborting
millions of babies
and people that support ivf then are
they bad people i think i personally if
you want to do ivf you do ivf because i
think it's a great thing yeah i just
don't think people who are
pro-life should be saying okay cool you
can't abort baby but if you really want
to and you're struggling have a baby but
through ivf yeah yeah
i think the thing for me is that
within all of this argument
there is also
the case for
this ban infringes even on
women who have been graped
incest
like imagine you're you're graped by
your dad
you now have to carry that child imagine
the emotional toll i would sooner kill
myself like real talk
i would sooner kill myself than carry
that child but that's but that's a lot
does my life not matter nor would i do
yeah
your life has more value than that
but at the same time one at a time guys
one at a time don't allow people to have
that choice
we're like i just that's not the kid's
fault that's not the kid's fault so
you're going to punish me for it i'm not
punishing i don't think a kid is a
punishment because you can give it up
for adoption do you not feel like the
person's mental health or the person's
okay the person who's living already
do you think the value of that life is
important enough that we should like
respect their mental health and
prioritize that before before murder not
to mention that the your rape your
rapist
can get visitation rights to see
the child
and like how how disgusting but also we
see this there was a very famous case in
ireland where and this was what helped
push through allowing abortion in
ireland was there was a case of a woman
she was heavily pregnant
she wanted the child she it was planned
she had it with her husband
she then became very ill
and the baby needed to be safely
medically aborted because otherwise it
was going to kill her i can't remember
if it was because it was an ectopic
pregnancy or being like a fellow i think
tubes yeah
so but i can't remember the exact thing
but just let me finish the
they couldn't legally and they wouldn't
give her an abortion because they said
no it's illegal we will be penalized for
it
the baby died she died she died
painfully of sepsis over a course of
days a completely unnecessary death so
in this case in this case here the baby
is going to die either way and now the
mom dies too if if the baby's going to
like most pro-lifers will say if it's
the if it's the life of the mother then
save the life of the mother yeah like
yeah but this law doesn't
repeat like again we're kind of moving
off topic because we're talking even
with grape like that's the exception
it's not the rule
it's it's not it's it's the same with
same with that like that's the exception
it's not the rule like same okay the
physical 92 of abortions are
committed for no reason
and every girl and honestly it matches
with what i've seen i know a couple
people that have had abortions every one
of them was irresponsible yeah they
weren't on any contraception none
that's crazy like and this is this is
what i've seen in in real life like i
don't know a single person that was
actually precautious